[Applause]
[Music]
mr wonderful kevin o'leary are you there
i'm here great to be here always a
pleasure are you in miami
i am i'm in miami right on the beach
nice do you have pants on
no pants
i just gotta you know i just gotta ask
around you had a recent trip to uh to
the middle east and uh you talked a
bunch about uh bitcoin and
cryptocurrencies regulation uh
infrastructure et cetera tell us a
little bit about the trip why did you go
and kind of what was the conversation
like with the middle eastern investors
well the largest pension or sovereign
funds in the world are in the middle
east and and i was i really wanted you
know this there's policies that comes
out of the region but then there's also
the opportunity to sit down and talk to
the leadership there about what their
intentions are
in uh specifically bitcoin mining i was
interested to see if there was a way to
invest together because
what they're contemplating in some of
these countries are sovereign um mining
operations
and so
what what is that going to look like and
so what i learned and this is because
you were talking about institutional
adoptions let me tell you what i think
is going to happen in the next 24 36
months
on on this very topic once a sovereign
fund decides it's going to invest in
bitcoin
it's going to want to mine it
sustainably and ethically because we've
got a lot of controversy started last
year i remember at bitcoin 2021
and the whole elon musk thing we've
talked about it a lot the conversation
around esg and his is mining bitcoin
going to be compliant with the esg
mandates specifically the larry think
letter the largest asset manager on
earth blackrock and so
this is what they're this is what i'm
getting out of this conversation and the
way i think i'm going to invest because
i've always wanted to open up my own
mining operations and i'm going to
probably do it in this calendar year so
number one
is it approved by the community it's set
up in both politically and by the people
that live there what's the plan to give
back to that community so let's take a
nordic country sweden or norway or
something like that where a lot of these
adoptions are occurring it's happening
in west texas too but the whole idea is
that you go to that town in west texas
and you you have an agreement with the
mayor and the city council like you're
you're compliant with them to start off
with you're going to give back to the
grid whatever it's going to be you get
them on board number two
can you
keep the
the award if when you get awarded a coin
can you keep it on the balance sheet so
i as an institution
can buy your equity i don't have to buy
the coin i don't have to go to my
committee and say i'm buying bitcoin
anymore i just buy your stock
and now i own the coin as long as you
make the promise to me that you're never
going to sell it because now i know it's
being mind ethically i know what's being
mined with the community in mind i know
the political environment there's on
board i'm not breaching any regulations
and now i own the coin and i get
exposure to the price through the equity
i tell you guys that's what's going to
happen this year you're going to see a
ton of capital go into these new
projects
some of them will use old chinese stacks
because they're all exiting the country
all that equipment and they're going to
be set up in jurisdictions just like the
way i described it with the equity being
the way the institution owns exposure to
bitcoin pricing and those are the deals
i'm going to invest in so when you think
about that um are there places in the
middle east that you think this will
happen or is it too hot there is the
political climate not ready for like how
do you think of the middle east fitting
into that because you mentioned the
nordic countries you mentioned places
like west texas is the middle east
potentially a place they got a lot of
oil got a lot of power production going
on there like how do they think about it
well they also have nuclear power there
too they have excessive electricity
available it's about the cooling that
you're right about that there may be a
way and this is being explored by a
couple of ventures right now to build
the facilities way underground in
underneath the sand like way down so the
cooling becomes far more efficient these
are really really large stacks we're
talking about big
you know close to billion dollar
facilities the way to start thinking
about this and i've come to the
conclusion is
different jurisdictions
let's let's take if you're an investor
like me you've got to find jurisdictions
where they're compliant with the local
regulator now the most advanced in my
mind right now
is canada canada was the first to allow
you to do an etf with bitcoin as the
underlying asset then they opened it up
for ethereum now they have multiple etfs
in that jurisdiction that people from
all around the world are investing in
compliant with the regulator
they just licensed the very first market
crypto exchange the very first in canada
i know that because the company i'm
involved in called wonderful bought it
last week for about 160 million dollars
it's the first of its kind this allows
institutions
or individuals right now it's focused on
ethereum and on bitcoin but it's going
to expand the mandate will expand and so
it allows for people to set up accounts
and actually do price discovery on an
exchange so we're very excited about
that so it's got me thinking where else
is this going to happen what other
jurisdictions are going to open this up
and licenses are going to be granted
eastern europe nordic countries middle
east regions so i'm on an airplane all
the time now i'm going to meet with
regulators saying look this is what we
did in canada
can we do this here
and when they say yes i'll invest there
too
i've i want to be
in the exchange business why because i'm
agnostic to price the more volatility
there is the better it is for me so if i
make 8 or 10 or 12 basis points every
time you're trading
i'm in a great place it's the picks and
shovels of the the future of bitcoin and
digital currencies and payment systems i
want to be part of the exchange all
right before we talk about the exchange
required one last question about the uh
the mining
if i tweeted and said kevin o'leary is
considering investing in an underground
desert
bitcoin mining facility would that be
like an accurate statement not yet not
yet not yet because the technology has
not been proven it's being
conceptualized but the reason you don't
see a lot of stacks in middle eastern or
desert countries is what you pointed out
at the beginning pomp the heating costs
are brutal i mean ours are the cooling
costs are insanely you know brutal so
that's not it's not time yet because it
hasn't been proven but each year the
technology advances if there is a
cooling system that makes sense they're
going to discover it because most
sovereigns want to mine bitcoin on their
own land
where they have control of it where they
can do it ethically and according to the
regulator's rules most people would want
to do that now west texas and the
governor in texas as you well know has
embraced crypto specifically bitcoin and
there is a ton of capital going to west
texas right now right down to the town
level and so there's multiple projects
there and i think you're going to see a
lot of capital and there's a big
initiative on right now to find an
american manufacturer for stacks so we
don't have to buy everything from china
for obvious reasons china's got itself a
little hot water here and there as you
know but we don't have that yet so
there's a lot to have happen i think
this will be discussed all through 20
2022 this is where the this is where the
puck is going so i've never told you
this story before but i went to kuwait i
think it was in 2018 maybe and uh while
i was there i was at an event uh very
well put together and uh there was a
both foreigners that were visiting for
the event and also uh kuwaitis and uh
one of them said to me uh hey do you
want to see a kuwait bitcoin mine and i
was like you got a bitcoin mine he was
like yeah and so we went to dinner and
then afterwards we went to this bitcoin
mine and it literally was in a warehouse
basement so like we went to this
warehouse it was kind of you know you're
like all right where are we and then
they brought me down to the basement and
they showed it to me and it wasn't a
huge operation but it was it was big
enough and uh i remember asking him why
are you in the basement he said well you
know one we might not want everyone to
know that we're doing this here but also
too is there's much more uh kind of
cooling capabilities down here so not
quite underground in the desert you know
type thing and not quite the skill
you're talking about uh but you know
years ago there were people who kind of
as an individual or a small business
we're trying to figure this out so it's
cool to kind of see that it's evolved to
the point where now you're talking about
large billion dollar facilities still
trying to conceptualize this and put it
into uh effect now tell me about the
wonderful deal so uh just so everyone
understands this my understanding is
that the canadian regulators went ahead
and they said okay we are going to
actually approve a regulated exchange to
trade in canada uh in the canadian
markets and wonderful and you uh decided
that you were going to be very
opportunistic here and you went ahead
and bought that license so that now you
own the only regulate uh
regulatory approved publicly traded
canadian crypto exchange is that fair
the history of the bit by deal is
wonderful itself had already made a bet
on bit by became an investor in a
private round and so they they already
were exposed to it but it was before the
license was granted there was a lot of
speculation that they would be granted
that license wasn't done yet but you're
taking a chance and you're betting on it
great management team fantastic guys
running it really knew what they were
doing and it amassed 375 000 accounts
because they were just a dealer broker
at that time like any other but the
exchange the market exchange license was
unique and new and the first of its kind
and so we already knew the management i
was really attracted to the model the
whole idea of having an exchange because
if you look around the world nasdaq new
york stock exchange the london stock
exchange the zurich borg all of these
places
are where you discover price and as a
result you are the infrastructure
of the liquidity and so i was really
attracted to that idea um that that they
would somehow you know get together and
they did and so as an investor i'm just
thrilled i'm very happy about it and now
um as you remember the wonderful mandate
was to work in the decentralized
space but what's going on here with bit
by is a centralized exchange with the
accounts so they've combined both and
there's a narrative coming into the
institutional investor think this
through pop
when i talk to institutional investors
about investing in in crypto
infrastructure anywhere
when you acquire a customer i don't care
if you're coinbase if you're wonderfy if
you're a bit buy you've spent money to
acquire that customer and if you don't
have a full suite of services both
centralized and decentralized there's a
high probability that if they want to go
put their nft on a decentralized wallet
they'll drift out of your sphere and go
do that on their own because you didn't
provide it so these new investments
these new companies that are emerging
are trying to figure out okay if i
acquire a customer how broad a service
base can i create can i be centralized
decentralized can i have brokerage
accounts can i service them in nfts can
i do you know stable coins can i stake
those stable coins for them i'm of the
opinion now as an investor i want
managers that are going to bring a
really broad sweep of service and
products to keep that customer in their
ecosphere this is no different than what
apple thought through decades ago and i
think there's going to be some companies
and i think one or five could be one of
them that emerged with a really large
platter of services
and not just in one geography i've
talked to management there i've told
them get on a plane do what i do go meet
other regulators go find out where you
can take this model to other
jurisdictions and i think that's going
to happen because canada's so advanced a
lot of the rules that they've set up
there have worked and i think they're a
great model for other countries and so i
think eastern european countries and
nordic countries are potentially great
places to set up shop
buy exchange licenses bring the
technology over the wonderful has that's
my investment thesis and i've in fact
increased my uh position there since we
last talked i've invested more all right
and so when you think about how this is
all playing out the last time we talked
you had said that you were spending uh
more time i think in partnership with
circle if i remember correctly uh with
the stable coin yields and you were also
looking at some of the decentralized
yields that you could generate walk us
through kind of the yield generation how
you're looking at your portfolio today
are you still doing both centralized and
decentralized what does that look like
right now i'm primarily centralized on
my staking and lending and so i'm using
two platforms and soon will be a third
uh with bit by
uh ftx is my largest platform obviously
i'm an investor at ftx and a paid
spokesperson i have to disclose that
i do a lot of staking on there pretty
well any asset i'm constantly putting it
out and generating yield there
specifically to usdc though i have
worked with circle circle just updated
their platform with a new treasury
feature the biggest problem we've got i
got to tell you pop this is still a
nightmare for institutions and it's a
nightmare for me
let's just take staking for a second all
right so i'm regulated i
i'm a regulated entity i have so many
investments in other
standardized financial services
companies and indexing and everything
else so i'm regulated i have an auditor
an external auditor they mark to market
my my internal compliance marks to
market my position every day and every
stock and bond i have it go it's checked
by compliance and then it goes out to
the the statement that the you know the
auditor signs and then we file our paper
i file our our uh compliance reports to
whichever jurisdiction we're in
so think about staking
what a nightmare
you need you how do you mark to market
that at 405. there's no such thing as a
the market doesn't stop at four in the
afternoon in crypto world it's just 24
7. so
getting this thing approved just for the
staking because i'm writing contracts
all the time 30 60 90 days whatever it
is
just getting the compliance guys head
around what we're doing took six months
i've told you this before and i j and
and what we needed was an audit trail
and they and circle just added that with
the treasury tab you can go back and see
every single transaction on a
centralized platform when it happened
when it closed what interest you made so
now the compliance guys are saying oh
this looks like something i'm used to i
get it i'm more comfortable now because
they were treating usdc as an equity as
a stock because we haven't had the
regulator approved i mean this is
another problem right what is usdc it's
not an equity to me
it's a form it's a payment system it's
software but we don't have that ruling
it and that's what i hope the regulator
does this year is rule on stablecoin
what do you think the ideal uh kind of
framework or sandbox for the stablecoins
are do they basically just say this is a
currency and treated like a currency do
you think it's some sort of regulated
asset how do you think of like the ideal
scenario let's take circle turn it into
a bank fdic
turn it into a bank
and
let my compliance people say oh that's a
currency
it's a currency and it's regulated
currency and it's it's backed up by x
amount of assets just like every other
bank
has to comply with the amount of
leverage they put on their balance sheet
and then all of a sudden i wouldn't be
bound by the fact that i have to treat
it like an equity so i can't have more
than five percent of it in a mandate the
typical mandates twenty percent any one
sector five percent any one name
very few institutions you mentioned
fairly earlier any of those funds that
they're managing you're not going to
find a whole lot of the funds that are
holding a position up to 20 in one name
they're kind of maxed out in the five
six percent range
but that but when you're dealing with
cash
or a currency a swiss franc or or a euro
or british pound
there's no limits you're basically you
can have 30 in cash 40 in cash 50 in
cash if we could get stable coins
regulated that way we could now
keep
our liquidity
in in my case i'd like it to be usdc so
that i could be constantly rolling it
because think of the problem i've got i
got cash
inflation seven percent i'm getting 20
basis points on us dollars i'm getting
taxed at 6.8 percent right now there's
nothing i can do about it i'm losing six
point eight percent of value the way to
stop that is stake out my usdc at six
and seven percent at least i'm keeping
in you know intact with inflation
but we need the ruling we gotta have
that done and for my compliance people
let me do that because i can't have more
than five percent usdc right now they're
treating like a stock
yeah it's incredible to think about how
is the macro economy playing into all of
this in terms of you mentioned inflation
obviously there's a lot of talk right
now about the fed interest rates and
kind of tapering what's your general
thought process on what happens there
with uh with the fed uh kind of
decisions in 2022
i think bitcoin and gold are the two
assets that institutions are eyeing for
a hedge against inflation and
so many of the institutions cannot hold
bitcoin so they're exploring owning the
equity of the miners and they run into
the esg problem so
and you know one of the discussions
going on these days about the esg if
you're buying carbon credits to offset
what some are doing some of the big
public miners
who's auditing that book in other words
is there somebody that can show to the
esg committee of an institution that
there really is a true offset the way to
avoid that is what we talked about
earlier simply get a minor that is not
there's zero emissions from the
beginning and that is mining and keeping
the coin on their sheet you just own the
stock i think that's where we're going
but
you know inflation's scary because it's
we did something in this country over
the last 26 months that's never been
done before we basically printed three
trillion dollars i don't care what you
want to call the program you know the
relief program or the ppp or whatever it
was we got out the machine and we
printed three trillion dollars
never been done in any country ever
before never been done here ever before
and then we thought to ourselves so we
don't have to worry about inflation are
you kidding like look what happened it
spiked up to seven percent in a matter
of weeks of course it's going to do that
and now we have to live with that and
the idea of another three trillion
dollars is is is suicide i mean that's
ludicrous we can't do that we can't the
buildback better is dead i mean you
can't put that out in the market now it
would it would destroy the people it's
trying to help you'd be you'd have right
now we have on on protein and meat 24
inflation i mean it's crazy and so
that's gasoline five bucks a gallon in
san diego like that's
people are getting pissed that's what's
happening and they're going to take it
out on the polls yeah one of the things
that uh i don't have an answer yet to
but seems to be happening is there is a
political appetite obviously for some uh
tapering let's get this inflation down
let's you know do some things to uh to
maybe um have people forget you know how
bad the economic situation is going into
uh election season uh but at the same
time inflation is still seven percent
you know gasoline's up 50 percent foods
up you know all these different things
even uh food at home or out of the home
is up six percent each like this is a
really dire situation according to the
official numbers we're not even talking
about the unofficial numbers uh when you
think of that is there a world where
regardless of what the political will is
that the central banks could be talking
about tapering could be talking about
raising rates and actually back off of
that and their actions aren't as severe
as the language or do you expect them to
follow through with what they're
actually saying in terms of kind of
taking a tough stance against some of
this stuff
it's a great question that's why we have
volatility back in the equity markets
because there are some pundits out there
talking about six hikes in a row and
some saying two so somewhere between
those numbers you know is reality but
you've also got this this this new
pandemic whatever you want to call this
this is kind of a different one than we
had 12 months ago but wow there's a ton
of cases i mean it's it's really uh
sweeping through
here in florida we have extraordinary
numbers uh they've shut down the
province of ontario and quebec
virtually shut shut it down because
they've got such a raging pandemic going
through there switzerland in the same
boat i'm just talking with my dad over
there i wanted to go and visit him
they've got over 30 000 cases a day
that's close to what it was at the
height of the original pandemic so
there's issues that i think that you
know the fed is looking at saying i got
to balance
this against what's really going on and
trying to figure out how fast does this
latest round of pandemic burn itself out
i would like to think by july of this
year
we're through this thing and and the
economy is going to come roaring back
what i find so interesting and this is
probably a great way to look at it
in q4 when analysts started printing and
q4 was almost six percent gdp growth
extraordinary extraordinary gdp growth
but they pulled back assumptions for q1
down to just over three they basically
cut it in half
i think this quarter that we're in right
now every index i've got including
private companies i'm invested in so i
see their tear sheets on sales the
economy is on fire it's just booming i
bet you we're going to print north of 5
in this quarter
it's going to be much better than people
thought this is my own take on it and
it's going to really buoy the equity
markets back up because when you've got
when you're talking seven percent
inflation you do not want to be in fixed
income you want to be in something that
at least
keeps pace with inflation that's equity
so i i think i think it's going to be a
pretty good quarter but it also may mean
that the fed is hiking but why are they
hiking they're hiking because we've got
such a strong economy and that generally
does not offset the pace forward on
constructive ownership of equities the
first few rate hikes generally do not
destroy a bull market and we are at a
bull market if you like that video
waiting you see my next one don't forget
to click right over here and subscribe